hey everybody Doug Walker here I'm sorry
Rob can't be here he has me head
whatever deep in submissions right now
it's like it's insane the amount we got
and are still getting so he says he's
sorry he can't be here for this but he
pretty much said his opinion is my
opinion when it comes to the one that he
saw which is x-men Days of Future past
so it's gonna be to be walks it's gonna
be bad it's gonna be Maleficent which it
just saw because I did the bum review of
x-men and everyone's like what you
really think what you really think so
this is just a quick follow-up as to
what my real thoughts on on the movie is
are I should say so
okay you can't you can't talk about Isis
v movie something like that in this
series without talking about the other
ones real fast I'll try to give a real
quick sum up of them just my thoughts on
I loved x-men growing up I love the
comics I love the cartoon I got the
cards I got like everything so when the
first movie came out I wasn't too
excited because it came out when comic
book movies were like the kiss of death
and you know how now you can do like
Thor and Captain America just there's so
much leeway and what people will buy now
and how much money goes into it that
that was not the case so this was trying
to be a little bit more of a realistic
send up and for as movies go technically
as a good movie it's not actually that
good because like a lot of characters
motivations there's a lot throw it in
the stories a little clunky sometimes
and they're just really trying to throw
a lot at you but as an adaptation and as
an x-men fan I enjoyed it it's a good
starting film and like I said this is
probably like especially back then one
of the hardest things to adapt into a
big screen motion picture and I thought
they did a decent job um like I said
it's still not technically good like you
know just Wolverine - Cyclops just hate
each other well okay forget any history
any development whatever they just tried
to hate each other and you know as saver
- the Wolverine don't have a rivalry is
stuff like that but I thought was okay I
thought was a good start
x-men two came out everyone says this is
like the best one out of the series um I
don't see it I like Brian Cox I like
some of the action I like Magneto's a
little bit more of a bad guy I guess for
me they're moving at the pace of the
Harry Potter films like who will give
you an eye drop of new information now
and it's I just felt like they were
going too slow and a lot of it was kind
of padding and but I like that crawler
like Brian Cox um you know and the kill
off a character at the end which is only
to follow through with this you know the
Phoenix saga I mean that everyone knows
what that's gonna be
and did anyone really care when that
character went I mean it's just I don't
know if for me it wasn't as big a thing
but I still liked it it was still fun it
was you know an OK follow-up to the
first one but it still seemed like hey
you were setting stuff up the third one
is where everyone says shit goes wrong
and everything they all go downhill from
there I don't hate it that much yeah I'm
the asshole I'm the asshole that does
not mind this movie that much but with
that said I know it's not good I know
it's not a good film but I don't think
any of them are really particularly good
but I I got to the third one because it
seemed like shit was going down like
actual interesting conversation starters
like that's along with the the cure that
can stop you from being a mutant and
whether or not it's a good thing or a
bad thing and how everybody reacts to it
and there's a war fought over that see
for me that's like yes this seems like
something that would be fought over and
this seems like now we're kind of
certain prejudices are you know if you
could erase this would you should you
yeah and I like that talk we're into it
was like they want to kill all humans
they want to kill all mutants and
something about the world in the balance
that just that's an immediate turnoff
for me because it's been done so much
and it's so obviously not it it takes
you out of any form of reality they were
trying to create for me so I liked what
they were focusing on the third one I
liked I liked seeing juggernaut I love
seeing beast kelsey Grammer's beast how
the hell did they
do that how the hell did they make such
a ridiculous design like respectable and
look cool and he was he was great in it
a lot bad stuff to lock characters get
axed off I mean thankfully ones you
don't care that much about one died
already
the the Phoenix saga is mostly botched
but again keep in mind this you couldn't
do aliens or any of that stuff back that
you just couldn't you know now you can
cuz Marvel's made just these giant leaps
in what you can do with comic-book
movies I mean and you can get away with
doing this stuff back then you just
couldn't um
I'm not saying that me I like what they
did with it um but yeah I kind of get
why they couldn't go all the way with
that but I still got to see a little bit
I got to see her going nuts I saw shit
flying and people blowing up didn't see
the Firebird that pissed me off they
build it up in the second one not to
deliver in the feral and it's so I'm not
as angry with it as a lot of other
people are but I see why it's bad I get
it um I just thought shit was finally
going down I saw some cool stuff I
always wanted to see in an x-men movie
so you know it's a selfish reason I'll
just very clear x-men origins Wolverine
came out I thought that stuck that was
my ex x-men three nothing worked the
continuity was all off the acting wasn't
that good the pacing was really bad okay
fucked up Deadpool which it's like I'm
not even like I don't know that much
about Deadpool but I just know if that's
not Deadpool and he's like one of the
most popular things like ever to exist
like in the geek circles every time you
go to a con that's like I mean you
cosplay as Deadpool everyone be like oh
holy shit they'll like you're suddenly a
rock star and they they did not do a
good job with that uh gambit was cool
for the two seconds he was in it nothing
adds up they don't even try to connect
it to the other movies really really bad
that that's the worst in my opinion I
think x-men first class was next that's
the only one that's like a legitimate
like this is a good movie like okay this
is the characters are good the story is
good everything
connects like there's some continuity
that doesn't add up but again the
Wolverine rude at all I mean so it's
like what can you do
but pisses me out cuts not my favorite
x-men are in it so it's like from pure
selfish standpoint I that drives me nuts
but I also acknowledge as films go that
is the one that's like this is a good
movie this is solid you know good acting
good story good everything adds
intriguing adds very well done though
Wolverine I just saw like last year or
was it this you know is this yeah
because it came out last year and it's
for me it was mostly a bore
I thought his redhead sidekick was cool
but I don't remember anything else about
it so it's not like really bad like how
some of the worst ones got but I thought
was very mediocre um but I did peep all
over the map on this if you say you like
it I get it you know it's it seems like
the most adult in many respects but it's
also the most boring so finally okay
long-long some of their the x-men movies
uh but you got no going into this
because this is like the umpteenth
version this is x-men Days of Future
past
Wolverine goes back in time to stop this
terrible future from happening a few
tries taken over by the Sentinels and
and he has to change things around to
make sure it doesn't happen based on the
very classic very iconic story that that
I read was younger too they did in the
cartoons you know and the point going
into this movie I was not particularly
looking forward to it because I actually
think this story is very dated and what
I mean by that even though it's about
the future you know don't get me wrong
it came out I want to say in the 80s
that the story was written in the 80s I
think and it's just terminator it's the
future is gonna suck we had to go back
in time to change it it looks like every
shitty future you've ever seen it's
ruled by machines you know everybody has
done this now so I really was not
looking forward to this movie believe it
or not I was like okay I'm just and I
was just done with x-men 2 it's like
look I love you but I'm I'm just done I
can't do any more but sure enough that
the movies going through
it's it's combining the first-class cast
with the with the original cast which is
really clever I mean really kind of
brilliantly done and you don't spend
much time in the future it's mostly the
only Wolverine going to the past it's
not shadow cat though she does send him
which comes out of nowhere just suddenly
she can send people's consciousness back
in time I unless I missed something but
he did not explain that very well like
why she Sully has this power you know
like I go through walls also as you know
at a low bonus I can just send people
back in time you know mutants whatever
and they for the most part tie in the
continuity and the characters and
everything very well and they sort of
have enough for the most part they have
enough space and room for these
characters to breathe and you know
they'll be their characters some stuff
doesn't add up like Maggie Magneto's
like you know you'll have to find me
it's important you find me and bring me
on this mission he does nothing to help
he makes everything worse I mean it's
like unbelievable what a bad idea that
was so but Rob Roblin good point he says
maybe he just he hasn't changed maybe he
still wants to fuck things over so could
be I don't know um you know all the cast
is great it's wonderful seeing these
people together you know the the young
magneto and the young Xavier and the
young mystique combined with the new
over een so it's it's really fun um but
I still wasn't like as good as it is
like now it's like it's a very good
flick I was still like and still I'm
just I'm still kind of dumb guys I'm
sorry it's like I'm getting through it
out of enjoying it it's good action good
acting surprisingly good story but you
know and I'm just not grabbing it and
then we got to the ending and I won't
ruin the ending but it is brilliant
fucking brilliant at cleaning up all the
problems of the last films like I was
amazed at how well this was done and I
don't know I haven't read even read up I
much I'll know people see it as a cop
like oh really nicely put together
ending but I thought was really inspired
and it was so good that the movie
actually made me want to see another
x-men movie at a point where I was just
done and this is what I realized about
x-men 3 they it was a big problem the
more the more I looked at it after I saw
this ending is that I realized I never
fully got an x-men movie really truly
because all the character you know at
the end of x-men how many are there for
going up to save another x-men or
something a half of them are knocked out
and stuff - how many of them are there
uh you know a few more but like half of
them are knocked out or being hypnotized
or whatever and stuff 3 they start
killing them off and in that's when I
realized it was a mistake to start
killing them off in three I like because
I was just like eh I don't care about
the characters they killed off and B I
was like just finally shit's happening
but I realized we never saw them all go
in as a group and all together and that
was part of the fun of x-men if he
didn't like someone there's that
character if this character is doing
this well then you got these characters
over here and they're all interacting
working off each other and even if you
don't like them I like seeing them
interact off each other and we never
really got that so this film the ending
of this film is pretty much saying we're
leaving it open for that to happen now
that is totally possible I hope they do
it because I I don't see it happening
because I know there's so many schedules
and there's so many kind of big names
now to throw in here you know and to get
them all one movie and god you'd have to
have like a fucking five-hour movie in
order to have all these characters in
there you know this one barely even has
bishop who looks cool but I love Bishop
God but I get it it's a movie an
adaptation and it's nobody knows Bishop
so you know I understand but it's like
these possibilities are suddenly open
and there's something legitimately
exciting about it so even if the next
one doesn't follow through and it's crap
whatever I'm still very thankful just
for that anticipation that the end of
this movie gave me the whole ending is
shot like you're waking up from a bad
dream
and it's kind of like that before the
audience do you just sort of go oh good
you know like that's mm that like so the
other stuff all the fucking dumb
mistakes you made before like they're
they're kind of gone okay all right I'm
I'm happy like and now we're allowing
you to have your x-men movie whether
they follow through or even can follow
through is yet to be seen but now you
can do Avengers you can do Thor you can
do all these crazy ass things that you
wouldn't be able to do whatever 20 years
in the past and now you can do them so I
I think it's kind of exciting
I'm really excited I like I said that
the cynical side of me says they're not
gonna follow through and they're just
either gonna bring back the old cast or
the first-class cast which is probably
more interesting honestly they're
probably the more interesting characters
but I want to see an x-men movie I want
to see all the characters together
working off each other have rogue come
across another mutant that she touches
for too long so she can fly and beat
shit up you know I mean bring in make
them happen we saw a bit in this one we
saw Iceman being Iceman again star like
in x-men 3 we're finally getting the
x-men acting like x-men you know he's
sliding around and doing all this cool
stuff we see Colossus we see all this
cool stuff is just the very very selfish
side of me who wants to see you know
like my x-men movie with all the x-men
in it really likes that stuff really
likes even just for a little bit that
little indulgence of hey here's that
cool x-men you remember here that person
is on the big screen and now it looks
like a possibility so hopefully they'll
follow through I don't know if they will
but I guess I'm just thankful to have
that that excitement again because it
kind of took me back to being a little
kid once more when the Zenda came up
that's how much I love this ending this
ending made the movie for me so yeah
that's pretty much my thoughts on it
Saurus said the same thing I think he
was saying more like yeah I was nice but
I I want the first class cast like
they're infinitely more interesting and
he's kind of right
you know but the selfish side of me is
just like nope I wanna I want my x-men
movie and what makes me movie he does
not share the same thoughts of the past
x-men movies by the way like I think he
he likes to the best from three on he
thinks they're shit so you know yeah in
that respect they're a little different
but pretty much all our other thoughts
are mostly the same so yeah guys that's
about it if you I'm pretty much doing
this because like I said a lot of people
asked to see it they wanna know my real
thoughts I think Maleficent will be in
here as well even though that's the
newer movie I get a feeling this one
will still get more views but maybe not
maybe I'll be popular so that's about it
I'll talk to you later
take care